hey guys yeah i'm also at a life and
death festival as well here at the uh
the
manchester down dario multicultural
center and
they have a lot of altars like christie
was talking about down here they call
them all friends we want to show you a
really cool one and we want to bring in
the creator of this altar
joining us now is consuelo
sanchez thank you so much tell us a
little bit about your altar we have
behind us here thank you um so we are
the clark county law foundation so we
work with a lot of lawyers and judges
on our alto we have some some judges who
passed away either this this year a
couple years before
so we put them on in our altar just to
commemorate their their passing and all
their life so we're happy to be
representing them here in our altar now
you know a little bit obviously the dia
de los muertos we're talking about the
altars and how they they honor the dead
not mourn but actually a celebration of
life um what about the face painting i
see a lot of face painting done as well
on this date right so the face painting
you know it's just part of
what we represent uh we're just
celebrating the death and you know the
school is part of the tradition so it's
just a way for us to call the dead out
so they can reach us in this life all
right thank you so much consuela
appreciate that thank you and of course
uh this goes all the way on until nine
o'clock tonight so you come down and
join us down here all right